pierre bédier va-t-il revenir en
politique condamné en mai 2009 à la
suite d'une affaire de corruption l'ex
député maire ump de mantes la jolie
ancien président du conseil général des
yvelines ancien secrétaire d'état aux
programmes immobiliers de la justice a
aujourd'hui purgé sa peine redevenu
éligible son entourage l'annoncent comme
candidat aux prochaines cantonales
partielles
suite à la démission de celui qui lui
avait pourtant succédés michel vialay le
démissionnaire qui explique avoir fait
ce choix dans l'intérêt exclusif de sa
ville mantes la jolie
il met en avant dans les colonnes du
quotidien le parisien le talent reconnu
et les compétences appréciées de son
mentor il souhaite ardemment sa
candidature ce sont ses propres termes
car bédié qui s'il se représente
et s'il est élu pourrait ensuite
envisager de retrouver la présidence du
conseil général des yvelines
actuellement occupée par l'un de ses
proches à marc schmitz un retour à l'ump
un départ du côté du modem flavien base
l'ex président des jeunes démocrates
yvelinois et membre du bureau national
démissionne de ses fonctions ce proche
de jean christophe lagarde rejoint l'ue
des îles union des démocrates et
indépendants
il s'était présenté lors des élections
cantonales sur le canton de versailles
sud est lors des dernières élections
législatives face à valérie pécresse
dans la 2e circonscription
il sera le candidat du centre et de la
droite à jouy en josas at il annoncé